of course I have to talk to you guys
about the big season 7 finale
[Music]
he's gone
[Music]
I want to know your immediate reaction
when you read what was gonna happen at
the end of the final episode if I can be
totally candid uh I wasn't in that scene
so I didn't read it she doesn't read the
scripts but she beat me to it
know if I can be what I was gonna say
for real is if I can be totally candid
um that ending went through many many
many metamorphosis before we got to what
it was that moment especially with
Elizabeth tearing out of the mercantile
and then and then she sees him in that
relief and then she runs into Nathan's
arms and then Lucas is it's um I mean I
just feel like that moment captured the
entire season and really put like a
button on the whole season of what what
was happening with the theme the overall
theme was for this year and it's very
poignant and I think it left a lot of
parties really I'd like to actually know
if people after watching that finale if
that changed which team they were on
team Nathan vs. team Lucas reading it
and when we were filming it I felt one
way about which which who I thought she
would end up with and then when I
watched it I found myself kind of
swaying quite a bit and then the ending
really left me more undecided than ever
how'd you feel Kevin I am a bit biased
because I I'm you know I read this if he
doesn't like one of the actors oh that's
that's completely false I tend not to
dwell on those scenes very much and I
think I'm kind of putting my head in the
sand a little bit because I don't I
don't want to lose one of them I don't
want I don't want one to win because
that means the other loses and I don't
know what that looks like in the context
of the show
no one's kept me up to date as to
whether the other person is sticking
around or not
sticking around and they are both such
great guys or something about those two
guys coming onto the show that is really
sort of brightened things a little bit
even more than we were and I just
covered incredible I agree they're great
guys and I don't wanna I don't want to
lose one of them so I tend to not pick a
side and I tend not to watch those
scenes too much because I don't really
want to be faced with it yet regardless
of who Elizabeth chooses the other can
absolutely stick around strike up a
romance with someone else
carriage and die you know you never know
in television you just don't know
well I absolutely agree I think it's
just I think a question more a question
of do they want to mm-hmm Elizabeth has
just gotten a book deal publisher in New
York that's amazing congratulations
thank you when we spoke on set in
September cabin you were team Nathan I
think the show was always about a
Mountie no less than Elizabeth his
character and her character kind of give
each other the gears a little bit more
kind of like that a scout you were also
team Nathan I was always thinking Lucas
and then I watched the season okay and I
saw that final moment when Nathan walks
out of me dog face so now that we've
seen a season seven finale I have to put
you on the spot and ask is it team
Nathan our team Lucas early on watching
this season early on I was team Nathan I
definitely still felt that's who she
should be with and I felt like a lot of
the scenes led that way and then Lucas
like just ah participate like and I feel
like pulled the rug right out from under
Nathan and was like I'm not messing
around I'm all in and and I was swept up
in that I felt like that's a really bold
ballsy move and I appreciated that and I
thought yeah this is who Elizabeth
should be with
then we had that last moment in the
finale and I felt like then suddenly I
don't know I really don't know I um
that's what I think sooner or later
you're going to have to decide I know I
think by not deciding in a way I'm
protecting myself from letting in either
of them Elizabeth we all have our own
paths when the time is right for you to
choose you'll know I think rosemary more
than anything has has been like the most
vocal supporter of team Elizabeth saying
I am just so excited that you are open
to the possibility of love
I think rosemary has been wanting to
encourage Elizabeth to go down that road
of just opening her heart out her heart
up and who knows where that'll lead
I think rosemary acknowledges she's
gotten in pretty deep now and a dis a
decision whatever that decision is a B
or C sure needs to probably happen yeah
rosemary seemed a little frustrated like
girl come on yeah and I guess Elizabeth
she's taking her time she it's not like
Elizabeth is just you know twiddling her
fingers she went through something
extremely harrowing so I do understand
the pace at which she's moving it's
respectful and it's a woman who who went
through you know something truly
traumatizing so I'm hoping in season
eight we see a little more progress one
way or the other I think this will all
be resolved in season eight yes I want
to applaud both of you because I've said
this so many times but it's so true you
guys are the Ricky and Lucy of the show
you make us laugh you bring us so much
joy but you showed us something really
dramatic and emotional in season seven
that absolutely brought me to tears when
we thought we might have lost Lee it was
a harrowing moment that I do not want to
revisit as a hearty cabin how hard is it
or is it hard to lay there in bed and be
completely still as all your co-workers
and you know the cast and the crew
everybody's running around you okay
quick stir
piece of cake reason is because it was a
cold day we were shooting this and I'd
been I've been nice to the crew since
I've been there and I'm professional I
do my job I'm trying to be respectful to
everybody so they covered me in hot
water models I was laying on a bed of
hot water models I had all over my body
so everybody else is freezing their
butts off and I just lay there
comfortable just went to sleep just had
a nap
okay so that was kill for you
Pascal was working hard I mean it she
will ever do such beautiful work Pascal
you should be so proud of yourself what
goes through your mind to to get
yourself in a space when you've got like
tears streaming down your eyes and and
we're seeing rosemary in a serious way
that I don't think we've seen her in a
very very long time I've always believed
you just need to be in the moment like
you just need to be your character and
really imagine what that moment is like
I don't I've never been a one for like
sourcing I just don't never found it
effective for myself to like source
outside of the character like I just
need to be in the character and in that
moment and from that whatever true
emotion will arise I will say though
that I I felt like to depict and convey
the severity of the situation I really
felt that we needed to see a complete
opposite of rosemary than we normally
see
Rosemary's normally so theatrical so
larger than life and I felt like for us
to really see how how profound this
moment is for her we need to see the
opposite of that no matter how much I
may want my child the only thing in the
whole world and I really need is you are
Lee and rosemary gonna revisit the idea
of starting a family in season eight
well we've been talking about it off and
on for quite a few seasons now and we
both feel that this is something that
has to be addressed it's touchy I mean
it's hard to figure out the right way to
go - which way do we is it a natural
birth
we adopt do me which way do we approach
this now we have a baby on the show
already we bring another it's it I mean
there are some mechanics to work out but
we both feel that that and n the network
and the writers also feel that it needs
to be the next evolution of this family
they these two are they deserve it they
deserve this and they've they've both
been you know this is a loving family
and I think this would be a good place
to bring a kid into and then I think on
an acting know Pascale and I would just
eat it up there's so much good material
there's so much fun and so much heart to
be ad that I think we would III vote for
an animatronic baby what do you think
they say exactly the same thing as Kevin
in that it's much like the love triangle
I this is a storyline that's been like
you know percolating for a long time and
we need answers now in going into season
eight and so I know Kevin and I have
been campaigning very hard behind the
scenes for more of a resolution on that
topic in season eight and what that will
end up looking like we've been
brainstorming a lot of ideas with our
writers and with the producers and we
have certain ideas we don't even
necessarily agree between the two of us
what what the right path is but we have
a lot of ideas they have a lot of ideas
and something will be resolved in season
8 for sure we don't agree and if they
don't write it we're just gonna make it
up yeah can you tell me what it is
you're disagreeing about she wants a new
reality
rosemary pregnant I agree I think I want
to adopt in-cabin thinks we should adopt
mostly from a logistics point of view
it's very challenging filming with a
baby the babies are unpredictable and
that's what I love and that's what Kevin
hates moving into season eight a lot of
fans would love to see more than ten
episodes and a two-hour Christmas yes
there's something you want to do
absolutely yes we have been talking
about this for a couple years now I
brought it up first Cavett did
and cabin when he first brought it up I
was like Kevin they're never gonna go
for it just you know don't this is not
the the battle you want to die on just
pipe down it's not gonna happen but it's
like slope you know he he's he's
whispered in enough times that it
started to gain some momentum and now
like the Hardys have thought on and it's
like normal Valley and we couldn't be
more thrilled I don't know how many
would you like to see Kevin I was hoping
for around 18 I think 16 16 episodes
which is only which is only six more
episodes and the Christmas so so I
substantial enough to make it worthwhile
my whole thing has always been this the
fan base is so loyal and so good in such
a positive fan base that I I don't want
to disrespect them or mess with them and
make them wait for such a long period of
time I don't want to lose them I think
that is such a giant gap between seasons
we we can lose some of this this
momentum we've got going it's been
getting better and better the fans are
getting that the base is getting bigger
and bigger I don't want to lose that so
I figured even if we could have another
month maybe two months you know six to
eight more episodes to keep it going all
of a sudden that hiatus is two months
less and we keep it going the momentum
keeps going I really think that there's
some discussion to be had here on this
one
[Music]